I was born and raised Muslim I prayed
five times a day and in Ramadan I fasted
for ten years I was taught Islam was the
only way to heaven and I believed then I
started making non-muslim friends
Christian said Jesus is the Son of God
and is the way to heaven and that was
another one of his arguments well the
Christians say you're going to hell if
you don't you know except Jesus the
Muslims say we're going to hell the hell
with all of you now so I mean what do
you say to that
assalamu alaikum how many job how are
you my brother I want to take a second
and and and address a phenomenon yeah
that's been happening you have a lot of
people who are Muslim maybe by name
locality and Muslim is simply one who
has submitted their will to the will of
the crit that's right right but many
people they maybe they go to university
right they have their parents teaching
them to pray they go through the ritual
they go to the motions but then they get
out into the world and some of these
things they get hit with they end up not
going to the right sources to get the
answers and they formed their own ideas
and that kind of goes with their desires
their lifestyle and they drift off into
the world there is a a nice young
brother that we're gonna go ahead and
look at his video and then we're gonna
kind of there's some of these points
that he mentions in these videos they go
right up into what I'm talking about
right okay you ready yeah
in life there are three things you
shouldn't talk about money politics and
religion so today I'm going to talk
about religion I was born and raised
Muslim
I prayed five times a day and in Ramadan
I fasted for ten years I was taught
Islam was the only way to heaven and I
believed then I started making
non-muslim friends Christians said Jesus
is the Son of God and is the way to
heaven Jews said they were the chosen
one Hindus said there's not one God
there are millions and my atheist
friends made fun of all of us the more
people I met the more I realized
everyone thinks their religion is right
and if one is right then fundamentally
everyone else is wrong
including me that is when I stopped
believing in religion
continued my belief in the idea of God
and decided to create my own religion
it's called nos ISM in which I tried to
lock myself and others to the best of my
abilities
all right before before we go on you got
a chance to look at it we got a chance
to look at it we love you nos and this
is a we taken attend this is out of love
that's a brother's name nos so he's got
to know that we love him because we're
addressing this have you heard some of
these arguments I'm sure you have well
yeah actually logically unfounded
arguments like if we if we think about
what what the arguments actually are is
that something which is complicated is
untrue so in other words because there's
many choices it cannot be the case that
the choice that I have decided a part of
my family I decided upon or the
environmental situation has put me in is
the correct choice there's a few
fallacies associated with this the first
one is a genetic fallacy just because
something is comes from a certain place
it doesn't mean it's right or wrong it
just means it just come from a certain
place just because there are so many
options of religions or let's say there
are six well or major world religions it
doesn't mean that okay one is right all
of them must be wrong is there's
actually no argument against religion
there then what he says about actually
making his own religion is actually an
ignorance of what is religion anyway so
what is religion trying to establish for
the human being
haven't you compounded the the problem
of man-made religions already that's a
good point that's a really good plan I'm
just gonna make my own religion yeah
yeah so if the issue is that religion is
man-made then absolutely you should
exacerbate that issue because you've
just now made another man-made religion
that a true religion for the most part
usually is one which refers to an
ultimate truth coming from a deity or
entity which claims to be a God now
Islam claims to be that and we would say
that if you if you apply logic
rationalism and also your own
predisposition you'd be most inclined to
the Islamic model than
any other model atheism the ones with
all that you mentioned a theism is the
idea that literally something has either
come from nothing or as the quran says
i'm holy human flesh a animal harlequin
what they created from nothing what they
themselves the creators of themselves
there's something either came from
nothing or existed eternally the
universe existed eternally which is
aside it from being aside from it being
unscientific is also unsubstantiated
there's no evidence for it number three
I'm humble harlequin did they create it
did it create yourself what did they
create themselves so the universe exists
and not exists at the same time also not
possible so atheism is an
unsubstantiated logical claim which
cannot be substantiated with logical
deductive inductive abductive evidences
and so at the atheistic position is a is
really I would say a response to
religion or to the failure of certain or
perceived failure of Christian religion
in the Western Hemisphere and that's
another response to the man-made
religions people see through intelligent
people and they just district reddit all
religions yeah exactly
if you wanted because because some
people do actually say a season is a
religion some people he mentioned
atheism as a region yeah many atheism
atheists wouldn't even put atheists
atheism as belief but they have their
own set of rituals yeah you know the
lucky shirt lucky charm you know the
aliens in the space they they have their
own set of beliefs at the atheistic
narrative according to post modernist is
a meta-narrative of some sorts it
attempts to explain the world in a in a
certain way so atheism is one thing if
you want to consider a religion I would
say it's one that is man-made it's no
doubt is something which is definitely
man-made if you want to consider as a
religion and something which can't be
proven to be true in any in any case
Hinduism has invented idea of a multi
plethora multiplicity or plethora of
different gods this this religion
doesn't have as absolutist a claim to
the truth as the Abrahamic religions in
the first instance you can come to many
different conclusions by looking at the
bhagavad-gita and the and and the
different the Vedas for example in the
the corpus the Hindu corpus it's not
really in the same sense absolutist in
its objective moral claims so in other
words it's a religion which doesn't even
make the claim that it's absolutely true
in the same way as say the Abrahamic
religions do then you're left with
Sikhism which is the sixth major world
religion which is a very recent religion
which once again some Sikhs would say
it's not an absolutist religion some
would say is an absolutist religion as a
difference of opinion but it's an
amalgam of the Hindu and Muslim legacy
of the Indian tradition and we can say
that Hinduism it doesn't comply with
either a strict monotheism and so much
as a it considers the Guru as part of
God and so therefore the idea of
monotheism is obscured with that notion
and moreover it's not something which
has offered any evidences to be a true
religion and despite it being a religion
which is born out of as we say other
religious plantations it's not something
which has the evidence which we could
say ok this is a true religion and
that's why state regional state in the
in the punjab region in India so we've
covered three the other religions now
talk about Christianity Islam and
Judaism Judaism as a religion really
which is not a prostitute sizing
religion in any rate it's not a religion
which claims to be for everyone
frankly it's a religion which which
really affirms this idea that the Jews
are the chosen people and that the
Gentiles are not the chosen people then
you're then you're left with
Christianity and Islam and then you ask
the question these are these are now the
the Abrahamic religions their religions
that are proselytizing religions that
are claiming to be absolutely true and
that have very solid truth we've
narrowed it down we've narrowed it down
so we were left with Christianity and
Islam making it much easier for our
brother my kin is affirmed yeah of the
of the of the major world religions
obviously Buddhism is another thing
which is not absolutely acceptable and
some people even say is a religion so
that's why I haven't mentioned it but
with Judea with Christianity and Islam
the question would be now on a
fundamental level which is more common
sensical which is more rational which is
more logical is it the idea that there's
three and one and one and three the idea
that the Father is God the Son is God
the Holy Spirit is God but there's only
one God which doesn't even add up
mathematically it's not rational and we
can trace the historical development of
the Trinity or the idea that God is one
and that he has he has a long line of
messengers that I've come before time
all of them with the same message that
there's no God to be worshipped except
for God and that Muhammad was the final
messenger sent to all of humankind as
mentioned in chapter 7 of verse 158 of
the Quran that he is sent for all of
human beings and so which you can you
can tell me now of what we just went
through which is the most rational
recourse in terms of religion you making
your religion doesn't solve any problems
it shows intellectual I'm not gonna say
intellectual laziness but I'm gonna say
it's just willing to engage with the
truth claims on an intellectual level
it's a good thing you're critical but
you're criticality has led you to
something which is really a a waste of
time in my opinion obviously but we do
say if you put your thinking cap back on
a pride apply the same criticality to
kind of assess now the truth claims of
the different religions then you would
be surprised that it might have been the
case but actually the religion of your
forefathers was the most appropriate
religion almost rational recourse
anyways we got a question coming in here
saying what would you say about a person
who just wants to be accepting of others
and not be constrained by the rules of
religion well I would say to someone
like that is that if you don't be
constrained by the rules of religion
you'd be constrained by something else
Rousseau who is a French philosopher
says man is born free but everywhere in
Chains man is born free but everywhere
in Chains you think you won't because
constricted by the social and economic
reality around you you will be and you
are and that is the reality that's why I
would say to them I'll say to them
religion is not something which is
actually some is confining its confining
on a superficial level but it's law in
particular is a religion which does take
you out of your physical and cycle a
psychological or comfort zone I'm
spiritual comfort zone but with that you
achieve what we would call a highest
state of being a highest state of
spiritual being of whom of living and so
this short term horizon thinking we only
think of immediate pleasures this
immediacy is something which is really
the Achilles heel of most people in the
world and the and the cause the major
cause of depression and anxiety for the
majority of people that live in the
Western Hemisphere
so I would say that to that person that
whoever thinks that religion is a
constraint to them or something which
constrains them that you shouldn't apply
that only to religion everything
anything is going to constrain you
you're living in a world where there is
an X amount of extraneous variables
which you cannot control and those
extraneous variables will do will
constrain your choice and your ability
to be liberal or otherwise free in the
space or the domain in which you live
therefore to apply this already to
religion is isn't isn't irrational you
could say so no it's not a sensible
recourse and I would say to the most of
that Islam spiritually Act it gives
meaning to everything you do in life and
that's why I really love this hadith of
the problem homicide Salomon she's
narrated by so haben it's a Muslim he
says hi Ben Lee I'm little McMinn he
says wonderous is the affair of the
believer in am rahul allahu khairan that
all of his affair is good well they said
that Kelly I had an ill a little
movement and this is not the case for
anyone except for the believer in a
Sabha to serve raw Chikara if good
things happen to him he's thankful in a
sorbitol da da sabor was shocked and if
bad things happen to him he is patient
and he is also thankful this is uh this
is something that's affecting a lot of
Muslims could you see Nass I said I love
your nas we're doing this for you Nass
and he used to pray right he's the fast
all right and then he went to the
University then you went to Harvard yeah
some people don't make it back what goes
on over there
people are getting a degree but they're
losing their Iman faith subhanAllah yeah
I have you cut have you seen these cases
yeah I've seen it when I went to
university in there in the United
Kingdom I've seen that it happens with
Muslims and Christine of the I've also
seen the opposite I'm seeing people come
to religion or on mass yeah and the
reason why is because criticality is
applied at that stage people start to
engage with certain things but I think
conventionally and traditionally and
also through culture people see you know
see the university experience or the
college experience as an experience
whereby you can start to experiment I
know what's going on look nice now the
people person or someone else feet for a
free
they kind of feel free from the shackles
what they think of religion yeah not a
guy gets a girlfriend you know he
doesn't want to feel guilty right so the
girls are there he's got a like oh you
know abolish himself of all this maybe
he's now he's drifted off but you can
see man from a person who's made such it
up before the prostration that sweetness
of it huh the door is always open to
come back isn't it 100 percent 100 100
percent and then to really know what you
I mean knowing when you know your Lord
the Creator they resistible Allah right
yeah and now you know like subhanAllah
being an a glory be to my lord the most
high many people making sajda they don't
even know what they're saying so this is
something that's so important to really
to know your Deen many people going
through the rituals doesn't matter you
mean fast in 20 years we had some guy he
said this person he was telling us we
had a nice little talk it was a
Christian and and us me my cousin and
another brother and he was talking about
you know flaunting how he used to be
Muslim so it's okay he was Muslim and
then we asked him well can you recite to
us and my cousin asked him can you know
can you recite al-fatiha he said what's
that so that's like my you know that and
I've done this many of times yeah right
or someone says yeah and I say can you
tell me the meaning yeah doesn't it does
that tell a lot it does sort of a lot of
these cases are disingenuous like
they're not actually rule cases yeah a
lot of people know they come out I'm not
saying every one because there's some
people that genuinely apostate yeah I
believe nos he was generally praying yes
going through you know but he just got
exposed the temptation the world opens
you know he wants to kick it yeah he
might be one of the genuine case yeah
well there also there was a range of now
disingenuous cases because people see it
as a path to notoriety like they feel
they become notorious
as a result of not saying that we were
next Muslims kind of past people now now
you've got certain segments of society
encouraging you to you know coming out
and building a fan base for yourself
just because everyone is substantially
the claim then okay and that was another
one of his arguments well the Christians
say you're going to hell if you don't
you know accept Jesus the Muslims say
we're going to have
the hell with all of you now so I mean
what do you say to that so they saying
just got everybody you know if I was
born in a Christian family I'll be a
Christian if I was born in a Muslim
family I'm a Muslim so you know well I
mean Hellfire is explicit in two
religions Islam and Christianity Judaism
doesn't explicitly mention the autism
doesn't explicitly mention how the other
Eastern religions it talks about kind of
reincarnation and what's referred to in
Sikhism was June and adjoin and these
concepts so that's the first thing so
it's not all because the idea of
everyone going to hell is that's another
mystery to me so I gotta deal with these
now there was a Christianity and if
you're talking about Hell then it wasn't
about Islam and Christianity yeah cuz
these are the two religions which make
it very very clear because people say
all religions so we again narrowed it
down yeah major world religions we have
nificant populations of people that are
following them so really is is so then
you have to assess the claims of both of
those religions yeah and and he didn't
deny the Creator he's smarter he said
okay I still believe in a law he still
believes but he now made his own
religion y-yeah yeah as you say the
composite yeah
and many people they'll say I don't
believe and that's the argument someone
like maybe him will make or other people
have made I don't believe in a
disorganized with any any any organized
religion right yeah so I'll often tell
people what you you believe in a
disorganized religion of course if the
creator made you isn't he the most wise
isn't he gonna have a system for you to
live by does that there's a person
create a company and not have everything
laid out a blueprint how it needs to run
that doesn't make sense
that's what is your Creator the most
wise so we do these things but then we
attribute why human being attributes
foolishness to God if you really think
about what they're saying it doesn't
actually make any sense doesn't make any
silly think they're the most logical
yeah they say we don't believe in
organized religion what let's actually
break it down what is what organized
mean organized is is where you try and
find a pattern or you try or you see
something kind of laid out structured in
a certain way you don't might not
believe in organized religion but you've
organized your thoughts to live your
life with certain precepts and concepts
that you live your life by and whatever
you call that if you want to call that
religion if you want to call that a way
of life if you want to call that your I
own ideology on religion
that is an organizational structure or a
framework with which you use to live
your life that's why the Quran says item
and attack allah allahu how have you
seen the one who has taken his God his
desires as his God am you know so in
other words you don't want to take Allah
as your God once I can go back through
so man is born free but everywhere in
Chains you'll take away the chains of
let's say religion organized religion
and strap on the chains of your own
framework that you've created which
might dfi in a conscious or Freudian
unconscious way your own desires mm-hm
as Jeremy Bentham was one of the
philosophers as I said that and this is
really interesting because Bentham came
before a man called John Stuart Mill who
refined liberalism Jeremy Bentham said
that and he acumen were reading this for
the first time in his book on
utilitarianism or something like this
his book is called he said you have two
gods you have pain and pleasure and as I
was reading now Allah this is exactly
this is exactly how people was headin
ISM it's cool but it's what the Quran
says the hadith as theis I have to deny
earlier than a Durham that may the
dabbed the the slave of the dinar and
the dirham which are two currencies ie
money be cursed so if you and that is by
the way I believe the biggest God of the
Western world now forget about
Christianity and forget about you know
atheism if you want to call that
religion I believe they be the the new
god of the or of the Westerner and of
other parts of the world not just the
West actually is the god of money that
is the god of money so you've organized
your life now capitalistic lee in line
with free market economics supply-side
economics in a way to try and maximize
profits profit maximizing and maximize
pleasure which is kind of like a gelatin
is more hedge anism
for the greatest number of people so
that is in itself an o as a framework
it's an organized framework how to live
your life so it allows you to do certain
things which which would enable you to
kind of have fun for the short term or
enjoy yourself in a be steel-type way
which is ironically against what the
liberal people like jay is not even
advocated he said that that's not what
you should be doing you should be
thinking more intellectually with
criticality but
despite that being the case you've
organized it so this this quote from
Marx that religion is the opiate of the
masses this is something which is it's
not even a it's not really an attack on
religion but it just is saying that
religion organizes people and I don't
see why that's actually a bad thing from
a psychological perspective like why is
it a bad thing you everyone is organized
in a certain way you've got your own
ideology so if you don't want an
organized religion you're gonna have an
organized something else
yeah and that's organized something else
is going to end up doing very similar
things is what the old guys religion did
you all right so we wanted to make this
this this short we're gonna cut out but
just hopefully I mean these are signs
that come to individuals not if this
gets to our brother nos and other people
who are struggling with these you know
struggling with their faith their
identity I mean these are things that
come to you and now you got to think
like you really got a you know and I
usually encourage people to dig deep
down inside because we I mean we can we
can speak and and bring you the logic
and the rationale yeah but it's all up
to you and then your relationship with
your Creator if you're sincere you dig
deep on site say Allah the Creator
you know guide me guide me help me make
that such day again right and it just
doesn't make sense I mean it's like
somebody having a a bunch of fake money
right and it's all counterfeit it's fake
so they give up on money altogether but
that's based off a real one the real one
is out there and the proof that there is
a real one is that these counterfeit
wants so they can be isn't that right
right yeah so the real one is out there
they just have to dig you know and and
when you dig and you're sincere you'll
find it in submission to the will of the
creator and that's Islam we have the
Quran intact tamper free tamper proof
it's a living miracle and it's there
what other advice do you have for nos
and other people who are struggling I
would say look I mean one piece of
advice keep it very simple here you know
we say 17 times a day at least we say
you know he did not stop don't stop him
that guide us to the straight path if
you do believe it but you said you
believed in a god if you do actually
believe in a God then I would actually
advise you to ask that God to guide you
because in the Quran it says for either
side like I read the and if any Adi Adi
Buddha ought to die at a time if you if
my servant asks me then I am me but I
answer the call of the caller when he
calls
where he also says in chapter 92 of the
Quran Isis in Nollan al-huda
certainly upon us as guidance so there's
two things you need to remember if you
are sincerely looking for truth ask God
for guidance and it's upon him to guide
you beautiful done we'd like to hear
from you now anybody else struggling
take this beautiful advice we'll see you
next time here on the deed show every
week subscribe if you haven't already
peace be with you Salaam alaikum
subscribe to the video follow us on our
official Facebook and Twitter pages in
the links below
please also help support the V show by
making a donation in the link below
[Music]